yeah so that happens first of all I'm
gonna let you know if you're not caught
up on Game of Thrones season three don't
watch this video if you have that
thought in your mind like well I'm
caught up but I don't see a reason why
he's doing a video now you're not caught
up go catch up for the rest of you
thanks for sticking around and yeah I'm
a little unkept today I'm unshaven why
because I'm engravings I'm allowed to be
because I saw that [ __ ] shaving doesn't
matter anymore cuz the Starks are dead
well alright correction they're not all
dead there are still a couple of stark
kids out there for the most part yeah
they're wiped out we're gonna talk about
this [ __ ] because this was some really
monumental [ __ ] once in a while I see
things that I'm like that's worth doing
a video on this wasn't just something
though this wasn't anything that's worth
doing a video about this was the red
wedding I had no idea I haven't read the
Song of Fire and Ice books I thought
filched from Harry Potter was being all
hospitable and [ __ ] we were there for a
wedding it doesn't get ahead of myself
I'm gonna back up I'm gonna explain what
happened in no way shape or form is my
explaining what happens going to gonna
capture the rapture and tragedy of the
moment so we're gonna try because I want
to talk I need I need to get it out was
the first thing I thought being
paralyzed and just speechlessness
I thought I need to do a video when I
can do a video about it right now I'm
gonna curl up in the fetal position and
sleep for 13 hours because I'm now
emotionally drained
okay backing up what happened we all
knew that Robb Stark was promised to
marry one of philtrum Harry Potter's
daughters they went back on that because
he found this really hot chick who he
connected with and hey who wouldn't
anyhow to win this war with the
Lannisters Brutus from Rome needs to
marry one of Filters daughters now
Filch's he's compromising so they're all
there it's a wedding but something's up
you know it you feel it in the air you
see it everywhere the entire time you're
looking around this there's a stone in
the air where you're like the axe is
gonna drop and I don't know how things
are too easy this guy is being way too
nice and someone's probably gonna get
screwed over little did we all know the
bride and groom go away to bang and the
bride is way too hot to be one of
filchers daughters right there I was
like something's up he's now the place
is cleared out and they shut the doors
and they lock it and re is trying to get
in to see her mom but she can't you see
guards running in you're like what's
going on brob starts there with his
pretty wife she's all pregnant with
their unborn child they're gonna
Eddard that's nice and then filters like
I'm sorry I've been a bad host Rob you
came here with your nice wife and I just
want to extend you a thank you or
whatever the [ __ ] he tells them warning
most normal people who have had a pretty
good childhood in their life or
generally speak and still have a soul
might find the description of these
events a little unsettling however I saw
the events so I'm right there with you
okay
you've been warned here we go because it
happens this guard goes right up to her
the pregnant chick takes a knife and
just gut stabs are a few times in horror
you're just you're watching this and
you're like you can see reaction shots
on YouTube of people watching what is
called the red wedding chicks are all
curled up in balls like clothes and
dudes just like that's what I was doing
I was one of these people I was just
like this I was like this in a horror
for about five solid minutes Rob gets
shot with a couple arrows everyone's
getting massacred in this place still
just just laughing cuz he's a dick
Catelyn Stark is hit with a couple
arrows the direwolf gets shot killed
that's when I knew I was like well Rob's
dying because the direwolf is dead Rob
clutches his dead wife in his hand she's
dead he's his hand on her stomach it's
all gross and [ __ ] Catelyn Stark crabs
fills his wife by the hair has a knife
to her throat and she's like let us go
and I'll forget this or I will kill her
Rob stands up you can tell he's done
he's like no she's like real happy he's
like you can tell there's nothing out
there
they've lost the stood comes up and says
the Lannisters send their regards stabs
him he's dead Catelyn Stark freaks out
just slices this chicks throat she's
screaming this chick dies this dude
comes up to Catelyn Stark slices her
throat she drops to the ground she's
dead and right now you're like I a sling
a nice little Greek tragedy okay no it's
not just a Greek tragedy it is the most
monumentally disturbing thing I've ever
seen on any screen whatsoever in the
screen movie screen TV screen computer
screen rule over two girls one cup
move over meatspin calm this is like the
9/11 event of television that might
actually include 9/11 footage that was
shown on television by that's pushing it
but you get what I'm saying
it's that monumentally disturbing thing
because we all got attached to the
characters at this point pregnant woman
getting gut stabbed already is it puts
you in a bit of
and that was just the warm-up round and
it was done my friends and I we were
just sitting there and we were
completely silent it would be in bad
taste to say anything so we just sat
there I just wanted to be like you want
to cool down with an episode of I don't
know castle read a couple of chapters of
mine comp something a little less
disturbing it's one of the things you
need to reevaluate who you have pitched
Game of Thrones - there are people
generally speaking if you're a human
being I feel like you need to watch Game
of Thrones there are now some people
where I'm like I don't know this might
not be your thing it's one of those
events it'll separate the Fairweather
fans from the hardcore fans if people
were like oh I like Game of Thrones but
you know this will be the thing where
they're like yeah I think I'm done
anything you do it's fine it just means
you're a human being if you keep
watching it you're also still a human
being but you're kind of like me I guess
I don't know what that means but the
point is we all found it messed up no
guy tugs one out after watching that
episode none any guy doesn't matter who
you are you can have the hottest
Scandinavian chick on your lap trying to
[ __ ] your brains out and you'll just be
like and that's just how it'll be before
this episode I had one thing on my mind
for three weeks one thing and that was
just a hungry Joey still have a dick I
don't know I think they took it I'm not
sure I'm pretty sure it's gone dudes had
a pretty bad couple of weeks now it's
just not on my mind there are priorities
because I do I just I just I walked out
of the episode going well that was the
Manson home videos that's interesting
probably not what I would wanna watch
every day or ever I have not had any
fictional piece of work impact me like
this because they're characters they're
not real people the real actors are fine
they'll live on and they'll be fine the
characters had a pretty [ __ ] day which
made me in turn have a pretty [ __ ] day
so I hate the show but I donated the
show I love the show I just say it's one
of those things and just I'm forewarning
everyone out there if you tweeted well I
don't know what the big deal was about
the red water just so you know you're
now on the FBI's watchlist for being a
serial killer they were like oh the
flagged another serial killer someone
wasn't affected by the red wedding this
was a pretty impactful episode this was
heavy gravity type [ __ ] I do like the
fact that it does illustrate yeah you
know that war between the Lannisters and
the Starks it doesn't matter there's
really bad evil lit [ __ ] coming from the
north and Daenerys Stormborn of the
House Targaryen has dragons you have
better things to worry about that war
was like a high school school
I'll tell you this though I don't even
that continent can rot for all I give a
[ __ ] come on Khaleesi - come over with
the Dragons over like yeah turn it to
ash they're either [ __ ] who need to
die or they're damaged beyond repair and
they probably should die out of mercy
sorry
Arya I love you but you're probably
messed up for life let's say that though
she's an interesting characters once
again she was just out of reach of
something so terrible she didn't die she
was so close this seems to happen it
seems to be she's one step away from the
actual bad [ __ ] but she's close enough
to experience it and see it so it's like
well that's permanent damage today I
turned on my TV and it was on game of
Thrones and it showed Phil - like
everyone sit down I'm sorry I've been a
bad host
I wasn't like doing this [ __ ] with the
remote tryna turn it it's too soon
episode 9 of season 3 of Game of Thrones
it's one of those things where you walk
in being one person you sit down and
then one hour later you walk out a
different human being you've probably
YouTube it at this point but you tubing
it won't give you the same effect you
need to grow with these characters for
three seasons then see the axe drop or
so the red wedding have you seen it and
what did it do for you yeah for you or
to you comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
the night is dark and full of terrors
you know [ __ ] lady saw her weddings